y
[Música]
francia obligará a sus ciudadanos a
vacunarse contra el kobe de 19 para
obtener el pase sanitario el gobierno
anunció que acelerará el trámite de un
proyecto de ley para instaurar la norma
en enero de 2022 como parte de los
esfuerzos para hacerle frente a la
propagación de la variante o micro
en filipinas las autoridades advierten
sobre una crisis humanitaria tras el
paso del tifón ride que dejó al menos
375 muertos cerca de medio millón de
personas afectadas por el fenómeno
natural han tenido que dejar su hogar
para ser trasladadas a refugios de
emergencia
los rebeldes de la región etíope de
tigre anunciaron la retirada de sus
tropas para abrir una puerta a la ayuda
humanitaria este conflicto lleva activo
más de un año y ha desencadenado una
profunda crisis que según naciones
unidas deja más de 1,6 millones de
personas desplazadas
gracias por continuar con nosotros hoy
daniela blandón esta es una nueva
actualización de noticias en france 24
iniciamos esta vez en francia que planea
nuevas medidas para controlar la rápida
propagación de la variante omicron de el
coronavirus en su territorio el gobierno
de emanuel macrón anunció que anticipará
la presentación de un proyecto de ley
anti covida la iniciativa pretende
imponer la obligación de vacunarse como
único requisito para el pase sanitario
es decir que elimina la opción de
obtenerlo a través de un test negativo
de menos de 24 horas la propuesta surge
al tiempo que sube la incidencia mundial
del nuevo linaje que obligó a la
organización mundial de la salud a
recomendar la cancelación de los eventos
de fin de año
la excursión un consejo extraordinario
de ministros se reunirá el lunes 27 de
diciembre donde se presentará un
proyecto de ley que le permitirá al
parlamento examinar el texto a inicios
de la próxima semana entre navidad y el
nuevo año aspiramos a una implementación
final del pase sanitario en la primera
mitad de enero no tenemos un segundo que
perder con la variante o micro hampa en
segunda pero su mayor unión
y médicos sin fronteras cumple 50 años
esta es una organización no
gubernamental que hace presencia en
zonas de guerra y crisis inició cuando
14 médicos franceses decidieron
agruparse en diciembre de 1971 y hoy es
una multinacional con más de 64 mil
colaboradores presente en 88 países
establecemos para hablar del tema
comunicación con él felipe carvalho él
es coordinador regional de la campaña de
acceso de médicos sin fronteras buenos
buenos días señor carvalho cuál ha sido
el rol de médicos sin fronteras durante
la pandemia y qué obstáculos también han
enfrentado
buenos dias daniela un gusto participar
de este importante noticiario bueno
nuestro robo ha sido principalmente
llevar cuidados de salud a las
poblaciones más vulnerables entonces
estamos enfocado en muchas poblaciones
que están alejadas de los servicios de
salud o que viven en zonas más remotas y
ahí llevar la atención a cubrir también
hicimos mucho trabajo de prevención en
muchos países trabajando también con
poblaciones de públicos prioritarios
como mayores en muchos países y claro
también intentando mantener los
servicios de salud y los sistemas de
salud funcionando en muchas partes del
mundo porque sabemos que también con la
pandemia
y causó una situación de mucha presión
sobre los sistemas de salud y ahí
buscamos también mantener las
actividades más allá de la respuesta a
cubrir también funcionando de la mejor
manera posible pero han sido muchos
desafíos hemos estado en más de 70
países con respuesta a kobe y seguimos
ahora también buscando ofrecer
tratamiento a la gente que está en la
internación y tenemos como desafío
principalmente el acceso a las
herramientas médicas como las vacunas y
los tratamientos que ahora están
aprobados bueno ustedes tienen también
una misión muy particular como ha
afectado esta situación la atención que
le prestan a otras crisis u otros
conflictos que atienden alrededor del
mundo generalmente
si es justamente lo que vemos hoy con la
situación de la vacunación es muy
preocupante porque vemos que hay muchos
países donde ya hay pocos profesionales
de salud ni siquiera estos profesionales
están vacunados y eso creamos una crisis
un problema claro para
es un público prioritario que debería
estar vacunado y la razón por no estar
es justamente en la inequidad en la
distribución de vacunas la inequidad en
el compartimiento del conocimiento para
que produzcamos más vacunas y en muchas
partes este profesionales no están
protegidos y muchos están enfermos y
muchos se están muriendo en realidad
porque no están inmunizados y con eso se
cría ahí también un desafío mayor para
responder a todas las cuestiones de
salud que existan porque hay muchos
países que ya estaban un poco
profesionales y ahora están con menos
por resultados de esta inequidad en la
distribución de vacunas de comida bueno
el señor felipe carvalho coordinador
regional de la campaña de acceso de
médicos sin fronteras muchas gracias
cambiamos de información y nos vamos
para filipinas el hambre y la
desesperación se están apoderando de las
regiones azotadas por el tifón rayo
centenares de poblaciones siguen sin
internet ni luz y apenas ven como las
ayudas llegan a cuentagotas algo que
puede elevar los saqueos y la violencia
el presidente rodrigo duterte promete y
recaudar más ayudas para afrontar la
crisis veamos el siguiente informe de
álvaro cordero
han pasado cinco días desde que el tifón
rai atravesará filipinas pero sus
consecuencias apenas empiezan a aflorar
aquí a la destrucción de cientos de
casas se suma la falta de ayuda
humanitaria algo que ha hecho que el
hambre se multiplique entre los
filipinos al igual que la desesperación
hide contento de lehman la cna no va
para delante hacemos un llamado para que
nos lleguen al menos algunas pequeñas
ayudas y un ponen al gobierno ahora es
el momento en que necesitamos un
gobierno un gobierno que esté listo para
ayudarnos en nuestra situación actual
para la vayan a meter en íntegramente
estamos esperando a quien tenga un buen
corazón espero que nos ayudará toma la
sala dame la falta de electricidad e
internet ha hecho que tanto bancos como
centros hospitalarios estén inoperativos
un conjunto de factores que ha
conllevado a los primeros saqueos ya que
las autoridades adviertan que la espiral
de violencia pueda aumentar ante la
incertidumbre de haberlo perdido
prácticamente todo
morano bueno monógama y cuando el tifón
amainó baje a mi casa y luego escuché
algo que se rompió ese fue el momento en
que grite para que todos salieran
sintiendo que podría ocurrir un
deslizamiento de tierra es lightning y
ahora me dejan ágata beaux draps farm
hace cuando cruzamos la calle y nos
quedamos en una farmacia vimos la
devastación de nuestra casa causada por
el deslizamiento de tierra de sapag
indicó
wright dejó al menos 350 fallecidos y
por lo menos 50 desaparecidos
convirtiéndose en uno de los tifones más
mortales en lo que va de año en
filipinas
los rebeldes de la región etíope de
tigre anunciaron la retirada de sus
tropas para abrir una puerta a la ayuda
humanitaria esto se produce en un
contexto de avance de sus tropas frente
a las gubernamentales en los últimos
meses el conflicto etíope lleva activo
más de un año y ha desencadenado una
profunda crisis humanitaria veamos el
informe
abrir la puerta a la ayuda humanitaria
esta es la razón esgrimida por los
rebeldes del frente de liberación
popular de tigre para explicar su salida
de dos áreas clave de etiopía acabamos
de completar la retirada de nuestras
fuerzas de las dos regiones de amarilla
farc al hacerlo creemos que hemos
eliminado cualquier excusa de la
comunidad internacional para justificar
su inacción cuando se trata de presionar
a ávidamente y sus socios regionales en
afganistán este anuncio es difícil de
verificar sin existir una fuente
independiente en la zona esta retirada
fue exigencia del gobierno de había med
como requisito previo a cualquier
negociación pero hasta ahora había sido
calificado de impensable por los
rebeldes que afirmaron hace unas semanas
estar a sólo 200 kilómetros de la
capital addis abeba pero a finales de
noviembre hubo una reversión de la
situación las tropas federales lideraron
una contraofensiva y el gobierno reclamó
varias victorias transmitidas por la
televisión estatal en poco más de un año
el conflicto ha dejado varios miles de
muertos y más de dos millones de
desplazados de jiménez el impacto
humanitario del conflicto es es más
dramático la inseguridad alimentaria
aguda afecta ahora a más de 94 millones
de personas en el norte de etiopía según
la oficina de asuntos humanitarios de
las naciones unidas solo en tigre hay 52
millones de personas casi el 90% de la
población que la necesitan
el viernes la onu dio luz verde a un
mecanismo internacional para investigar
los abusos cometidos por todas las
partes en etiopía
a ustedes gracias por su sintonía los
invitamos a mantenerse informados en
france 24 y en france 24 punto com feliz
día
[Música]